well it's finally official Hillary
Clinton is the Democratic nominee for
president of the United States her
journey to get the nomination from
lawyer to wife of a governor first lady
to senator to Secretary of State and now
the presidential nominee is rivaled only
by Palpatine's monumental rise to
emperor of the first Galactic Empire
actually if you look closely they do
we're very similar clothes but I'm going
to leave that comparison right there so
first off I don't want to gloss over the
fact that Hillary is the first female
nominee by a major party to be President
you guys know that I do not like
identity politics so I'm not going to
make this all about her being a woman
but I think it's important for us to
acknowledge this fact from now on little
girls across America can grow up and
know that they too can have a chance at
being president being a woman won't
inherently make them better or worse for
the job as the leader of the free world
but they'll know that the trail has been
blazedd before them and by the way we
shouldn't forget that it hasn't even
been a hundred years since women got the
right to vote in America we're not even
going to hit that anniversary for
another three years in 2019 but beyond
being a woman as many people have
pointed out Hillary is basically the
most qualified person ever to be
nominated as I said just the second ago
her entire life has led to this moment
her Road gut goes not only from being a
lawyer but also to a senator and
Secretary of State as well as someone
that spent eight years living in the
White House many people argue that her
experience is exactly the reason not to
vote for her we talk about a broken
system and she's as ingrained in the
system as anyone could possibly be and I
think that is a completely fair point
people like experience when their
candidate has it and people like a clean
slate when their candidate lacks it kind
of funny how that works out right this
Democratic convention has been largely
about Hillary getting Bernie his
supporters and his delegates on her side
Bernie has been a total team player in
this regard much to the chagrin of many
of his supporters at the end of the day
bernie is now supporting a person who
raised more Wall Street money and big
donor money than any
on the campaign trail and who has helped
build the very messed up system he's
been railing against for 25 years Bernie
could have said forget this and tried a
third-party run but ultimately he fell
in line with the party that clearly
didn't want him to win what his
endorsement of Hillary will do for his
legacy and his message against the
system we won't know for years but at
the end of the day right this very
second he's supporting the exact system
that he was fighting against I've said
many times that I don't like the idea of
Hillary as president because i don't
want political dynasties we had a bush
Nana Clinton than a bush that Obama now
maybe a Clinton then maybe Chelsea
Clinton then maybe Malia Obama and then
who knows let's not forget that we left
England a long time ago because we
didn't want to be ruled by a monarchy my
feelings for Hillary have been tepid at
best I don't think she's the
warmongering neocon progressives had
made her out to be but I also don't
think she's a sinister globalist like
right-wing radio hosts will tell you at
times I've mocked her and at times I've
defended her at the end of the day I
think she's just like the rest of them a
politician looking to gain more power
she's just better than most of them
added maybe that's why they hate her so
much don't hate the player hate the game
or in Bernie's case hate the game but
then endorsed the hell out of it once
you lose I'm pretty sure I speak for a
lot of us when I say I wish we had more
choices in front of us in this election
I think you can make solid cases for
both Clinton and Trump just as you can
make damning condom nations of them both
if the founding fathers were here to see
this they might tell us to board a ship
find some new land and try all over
again but maybe just maybe the brilliant
document that they wrote the
Constitution will be enough to weather
any storm that's coming our way let's
not forget the president is only
one-third of the government we have a
brilliantly designed system of checks
and balances to safeguard our freedoms
and make sure that whoever is our
president never becomes our Emperor
while the atmosphere feels incredibly
toxic right now and we've still got over
three more months of this god help us
let's not lose sight that the best
government is one that you don't have to
think about that much because it simply
were
that's why at the very least i'd love to
see libertarian gary johnson get to
fifteen percent in the polls so they
have to include an alternate voice in
the debate there are way more ideas out
there than just the ones that clinton
and trump or giving us at the end of the
day whether you want to make America
great again or whether you're with her
we're all in this together so let's try
to find some common ground
you